the best action sequences I've seen in a
spy movie since Mission Impossible
fallout granted this bit of about a week
still pretty impressive the spy who
dumped me so the spy who dumped me is a
spy comedy starring Mila Kunis and Kate
McKinnon Mila Kunis has this boyfriend
turns out he's a spy he gets wasted
there on the room with the package which
just wraps them into the spy adventure
I thought Mila Kunis and Kate McKinnon
were firemen if I'm an honest Kate
McKinnon at this point I'm like alright
she's gonna I've seen her character I
feel like she basically does a lot of
the same characters at this point so
this movie she actually she wasn't so
much an exaggeration of a human being
that she usually is that's the moment of
that but that wasn't the basis of her
character in this movie so I appreciated
that I will say the comedy in this movie
doesn't always landform is 50/50 I could
flip two phases coin to see if I liked
it or not but when the movies not trying
to be funny that's when it's most funny
which is what I've heard some people say
about my channel which I get but if I'm
giving credit where credit is due some
of the action sequences in this movie
pretty good they're more becoming of an
actual attempt at an actual spy film not
a comedy that's oh by the way it's a spy
film some of the hits in one of the car
chase sequences I was like this is like
it's out of a Mission Impossible movie
that's not to say this movie has the
brains of a Mission Impossible movie at
a point in this movie Kate MacKinnon's
character did start to annoy me a little
bit kate MacKinnon's character does walk
a line for me as to whether or not I'm
gonna write them off as a complete idiot
I know they're not supposed to be
efficient because they're not supplies
at all they're normal human beings
who've been wrapped up in this thing but
a couple of times near the end she makes
a couple of calls where I'm like don't
do that do not do that thing and she
does that thing the movie does feel a
bit too long it does show cinematic
relativity when it comes to runtime you
can have a movie that's three hours long
that feels just right whereas you can
have a movie that's an hour and a half
long that feels too long it feels padded
with garbage it doesn't age and it
usually comes from how a movie delivers
its beginning middle and it's set up
climax conclusion so when I saw a
seemingly beginning middle and end arc
play out in this movie I was like
alright we're done because it seems like
it's been on for two hours that's how my
brain picked it up because I saw an
entire cinematic art can I check my
watch I was like oh this movies been on
for just over an hour and at that point
the movie instantly seemed too long I
felt like I was at my destination it
turns out when I asked are we there yet
I was met with the answer we're halfway
there because in the end a spy who
dumped me it's like an amalgamation that
was half-assed on everything except the
action is pretty good there but it's not
funny enough to stand out as a comedy
it's not clever enough to stand
as a spy movie it doesn't have enough of
the great action in it to say it's
actually an action movie it's pretty
middle-of-the-road
kind of forgettable in fact I'm not
gonna remember the movie in t-minus a
couple days ya already forgot all right
so the spy who dumps me have you seen it
what did you think about it or what's
your favorite spy comedy whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know
totally gotcha isn't it I know it's got
you and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]